ça y est c'est officiel le franc cfa
c'est terminé critique est souvent vu
comme un reste des colonies il va céder
sa place à l'éco une nouvelle monnaie en
2020 on vous explique ce qui va changer
déjà le nom bon c'est vrai qu'à la base
francs cfa ça voulait dire franc des
colonies françaises d'afrique pour
finalement devenir franc de la
communauté financière africaine mais en
gardant le sigle au cfa ce qui pouvait
faire de tâches avec l'écho au moins
tout le monde est d'accord
ensuite et c'est une avancée
significative
la banque centrale des pays d'afrique ne
devra plus d'épouser à moitié de ses
réserves de change auprès de la banque
de france comme c'était le cas avec au
franc cfa une dépendance souvent jugée
humiliante par de nombreux pays
africains la france ne sera plus
présente au sein de l'union monétaire
africaine
même si elle garde un rôle de garant
elle n'aura plus son mot à dire sur
l'économie des pays africains
quoi de plus normal je fouille pas dans
les comptes de mon voisin mois ar mais
attention s'il y a des changements
louable il y a quand même quelque chose
qui ne bouge pas les koalas nouvelle
monnaie comme l'ancienne sera toujours
aligné sur north est l'un des points qui
posent le plus de problèmes
le roux étant une monnaie forte elle
pénalise l'économie des pays concernés
qui doivent lutter contre l'inflation
de travailler en priorité à la
croissance économique des avancées
significatives donc mais pas encore un
changement total
décidément cet écho à encore déserte
francs cfa